ce n'est probablement pas votre homme votre vermine
quel âge avez-vous faites ce que vous voulez faites
vraiment ce que vous voulez avoir votre rêve dans
la tête n'est rien si vous devez
travailler pour cela vous devez travailler travailler travailler
oubliez tous les gens qui vous disent que vous pouvez le
faire  c'est non non non tu peux
[Musique] la
boxe pour beaucoup de gens n'est qu'un sport
mais pour moi c'est la vie je fais tout pour
ma boxe si je fais du fitness c'est
pour ma fête si je cours c'est pour mon
siège auto au travail je  pense à la boxe
vraiment la boxe c'est c'est ma vie je ne serai
pas champion
[Musique]
je sais moi un jour je champagne vraiment du
champagne mais je dois travailler pour ça
sans travail
on rêve juste c'est pas possible
[Musique]
symposium Kamandi manscape Ocampo  dans via
port boîte à clés féminine un passif sur ESP
remem cabinetry petra peur allah la
vidéo le côté de son un arc sur la latitude
sur la zone difficile être invisible
musique étrange sur votre table ce n'est qu'un
début
je ne serai plus plus plus j'ai gagné
Je ne suis pas champion maintenant je ne suis pas champion ouais ouais
qu'est-ce que
c'est  en vous entraînant tous les jours, vous ne serez tout simplement
pas parfait comme vous le pouvez
[Musique]
J'aime hawaïen
J'aime vivre ici ici tout le monde
ressemble à ma famille ils m'aideront
pour ma boxe pour ma vie pour mon travail car
tout est parfois difficile mais  alors
tu crois quelque chose avec ton cœur
tu sais que cette situation n'est pas pour
toujours toi tout le monde tout le monde que
tu ne vois pas maintenant est une star qui a du succès
réussir ils ont la vie dure
[Musique]
tous les matins j'envoie le premier
message à ma mère Dada bonjour comment vas-tu j'espère
passer une bonne journée tous les jours et mes amis
en Iran ils m'envoient un message sur
instagram whatsapp ça va et j'ai
prévu de les inviter ici en France -
Je les vois parce qu'ils me manquent vraiment